[Music]  i told you they wouldn't score yeah  the playoffs are upon us so you better  make sure your setup's right  but lucky for you i got the echo system  remember you gotta find the best spot in  the house  and be exact it's beautiful  with the lg oled picture quality you can  still see the game  even if you don't want to no defense  come on man you can't let that happen  gosh this brings me to my next point  don't punch the wall  but because of these self-lit pixels on  this tv you can see the good part of my  hand  and what the doctors called  busted just because you're watching  football  doesn't mean you can't class it up  [Music]  my new feet so it's halftime  so it's time to go viral doing my  halftime show  [Music]  even in today's world you don't have to  enjoy the game alone  kayla you're my guest you got to eat i  told you they wouldn't score  touchdown  so there you have it follow the echo  system and your home viewing experience  will be legendary